ahora veamos un compuesto con dos
centros quirales nuestro objetivo es
terminar de nombrar esta molécula sin
numerados los carbonos este es el
carbono 1 2 3 4 y 5 observen que tenemos
1 h en el carbono 2 y como en total
tenemos 5 carbonos por eso el 2 ventanal
y tenemos un grupo metilo en el carbono
3 por eso se llama 3 metil 2 ventanal
pero aún nos falta poner la estéreo
química sabemos que el carbono 2 es un
centro quiral y el carbono 3 es otro
centro quiral así que usaremos el
sistema rs para completar el nombre
primero veamos el carbono 2 determinemos
la configuración de este centro que irá
aquí tenemos 1 h hacia nosotros y
también tenemos un hidrógeno lejos de
nosotros ahora del lado izquierdo el
centro que irá al estado unido
directamente
carbono y este carbono está unido a tres
hidrógenos después del lado derecho
tenemos otro carbono pero este carbono
está unido a un carbono un carbono y un
hidrógeno que se encuentra hacia
nosotros entonces asignemos la prioridad
de los cuatro grupos que es el paso 1
para determinar la configuración de un
centro que irán
este es nuestro centro que irán y unidos
6 de carbono tenemos un oxígeno un
hidrógeno un carbono del lado izquierdo
y un carbono del lado derecho
ahora para asignar la prioridad podemos
basarnos en el número atómico verán de
todos estos átomos el oxígeno tiene el
mayor número atómico entonces el grupo o
h es el número 1 mientras que el
hidrógeno como tiene el número atómico
más bajo es el número 4 ok
después tenemos 2 carbonos tienen el
mismo número atómico
para saber quién gana podemos analizar
los átomos a los que están unidos por
ejemplo el carbono de la izquierda está
unido a tres hidrógenos vamos a escribir
tres hidrógenos y el carbono de la
derecha está unido a dos carbonos y un
hidrógeno entonces carbono carbono
hidrógeno vamos a ver aquí tenemos un
carbono y aquí tenemos un hidrógeno pero
como el carbono tiene un mayor número
atómico
este grupo gana así que el grupo de la
derecha tiene mayor prioridad es el
número 2 y por lo tanto el grupo metilo
es el número tres ya que asignamos la
prioridad el siguiente paso es orientar
la molécula para que el grupo de menor
prioridad quede hacia atrás en este caso
el grupo de menor prioridad es el
hidrógeno y se encuentra lejos de
nosotros así que simplemente podemos
ignorarlo y solo tomamos en cuenta el
grupo
1 2 y 3 voy a reescribir lo del lado
izquierdo y lo h es el número 1 el grupo
de la derecha es el número 2 y el grupo
metilo es el número 3
entonces si dibujamos un círculo que
pase por 1 2 y 3
miren nos movemos en la misma dirección
de las manecillas del reloj así que la
configuración es earl si tenemos una
configuración r en el carbono 2 podemos
escribir 2 r ahora enfoquémonos en el
carbono 3 el carbono 3 también es un
centro que irá pero que tenemos unido a
este carbón
bueno aquí tenemos un carbono unido a 3
hidrógenos es un grupo metilo por acá
tenemos un hidrógeno que se encuentra
hacia nosotros después del lado derecho
tenemos un carbono unido a dos
hidrógenos y
este carbono está unido a otro carbón y
del lado izquierdo
tenemos un carbono que está unido a un
oxígeno también a un hidrógeno lejos de
nosotros y este carbono está unido a
otro carbono asignemos la prioridad a
los cuatro grupos
este es nuestro centro quiral y unidos a
este carbono tenemos tres carbonos 1 2 3
y también tenemos un hidrógeno que como
sabemos tiene el número atómico más
pequeño así que es el grupo número 4 y
después tenemos 3 carbonos tienen el
mismo número atómico así que necesitamos
analizar los átomos que están unidos a
esos carbonos empecemos con el carbono
de la derecha este carbono está unido
directamente a un carbono y dos
hidrógenos vamos a escribirlos en orden
decreciente del número atómico
carbono hidrógeno hidrógeno ahora el
carbono de abajo está unido directamente
a tres hidrógenos entonces 1 2 3 y el
carbono de la izquierda está unido a un
oxígeno un carbono y un hidrógeno que si
los escribimos en orden decreciente del
número atómico nos queda oxígeno carbono
e hidrógeno ok vamos a comparar primero
tenemos carbono hidrógeno y oxígeno de
esos tres átomos el oxígeno tiene el
número atómico más alto así que este
grupo tiene mayor prioridad el grupo con
él o h es el número uno después seguiría
el carbono porque el carbono tiene un
número atómico más alto que el hidrógeno
entonces el grupo de la derecha el
estilo es el número 2 y finalmente el
grupo metilo es el número tres ya que
asignamos prioridades el paso 2 es
entrar la molécula para que el grupo de
menor prioridad quede lejos de nosotros
aquí el hidrógeno se encuentra hacia
nosotros y eso no es lo que queremos
nosotros necesitamos que el hidrógeno
quede lejos de nosotros entonces algo
que podemos hacer es imaginar que un eje
pasa por el centro girar y así podemos
rotar la molécula para que el hidrógeno
quede hacia atrás pero veamos el
siguiente vídeo para que podamos
visualizar lo mejor
este es nuestro compuesto en el carbono
2 tenemos 1 h hacia nosotros y en el
carbono 3 tenemos un grupo metilo lejos
de nosotros si ponemos un eje en este
carbono y rotamos la molécula veamos qué
pasa con esos grupos ahora en el carbono
2 el o h está lejos de nosotros y en el
carbono 3
el grupo metilo está hacia nosotros
ahora dibujemos el compuesto con el
hidrógeno lejos de nosotros primero
pongamos la cadena de carbonos sabemos
que en el carbono 2 tenemos un h lejos
de nosotros vamos a dibujarlo aquí
tenemos el h y después en el carbono 3
el grupo metilo se encuentra hacia
nosotros vamos a ponerlo y después
tenemos un hidrógeno lejos de nosotros
no podemos verlo muy bien en la
fotografía pero sabemos que ahí está
entonces el grupo con el h tiene la
prioridad más alta es el número 1
también sabemos que el grupo de tilo es
el número 2
el grupo metilo es el número 3 y el
hidrógeno es el número 4 y como ya
tenemos el grupo de menor prioridad
lejos de nosotros si lo ignoramos
podemos ver que nos movemos en esta
dirección es decir en contrarreloj así
que la configuración es
la configuración en el carbono 3 es ese
y podemos completar el nombre
escribiendo 3s entonces este compuesto
es el 2 r 3 ps3 metil dos ventanas pero
qué harían si no quieren rotar la
molécula bueno pueden usar el truco que
les mostré en el vídeo anterior
regresemos al dibujo de la izquierda hay
un pequeño truco que podemos usar en
este caso si el hidrógeno se encuentra
hacia nosotros podemos simplemente
ignorarlo y observar la secuencia 1 2 3
miren de 1 a 2 y a 3 vamos en esta
dirección que es como la de las
manecillas del reloj así parece que la
configuración es r parece er pero como
el hidrógeno se encuentra hacia nosotros
en realidad será lo contrario es decir
parece r pero como el hidrógeno está
hacia nosotros entonces debe ser ese
este es un buen truco para que no
tengamos que rotar la molécula en
nuestra cabeza